voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire sur la
situation et cette guerre qui a lieu en
ce moment en ukraine on va passer
maintenant la politique en france la
campagne présidentielle bat son plein
nous sommes un peu plus d'un mois du
premier tour de la présidentielle
nous recevons ce matin françois
asselineau bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes le président de l'union
populaire républicaine vous êtes
candidat à la présidentielle pour le
moment vous n'avez pas encore réuni les
500 parrainages nécessaires pour vous y
présenter on y reviendra dans un instant
mais d'abord cette question quelle est
votre réaction face à ce qui est en
train de se passer en ukraine quelle est
votre position vis-à-vis de la décision
de vladimir poutine d'envahir l'ukraine
alors vous savez quand il une guerre et
un dicton qui dit la première victime
c'est la vérité donc ce que j'essaie de
faire moins depuis quinze ans que j'ai
créée lui prc il de dire la vérité la
vérité c'est quoi c'est premièrement que
poutine l'a a violé le droit
international et j'observe effectivement
qu'à l'assemblée générale des nations
unis en se réfugiant derrière la charte
des nations-unies en effet les assemblée
a voté très majoritairement contre la
russie c'est normal parce qu'il doit
être condamné on n'a pas le droit
d'intervenir dans un autre état
militairement sauf si on a
l'autorisation du conseil de sécurité le
chapitre 7 ça c'est un premier point la
deuxième point c'est qui vient aussi le
deux poids deux mesures qui est
insupportable parce que je vais pas ici
à égrener le nombre de violation de la
charte notamment par les etats-unis
lorsqu'ils ont bombardé l'irak ou bien
par la france dans ce qu'elle a bombardé
la libye donc prendre monsieur poutine
comme si c'était une espèce de diable
est sorti d'un chapeau et que tout le
monde appliquaient la jaf c'est faux
troisièmement pourquoi est-ce que
poutine a fait ça c'est parce que ça
fait quand même des années et des années
que l'otan essaye de grignoter et de se
rapprocher de plus en plus des
frontières de la russie il n'y a pas de
troupes en ukraine de l'otan maintenant
il n'y a pas de troupes mais il ya décès
il ya des formateurs canadiens notamment
qui forment l'armée quelles armes ils
craignent elle est justement puisque
veut poutine c'est empêcher que le crème
de vienne ce qui s'est passé en estonie
en et en lettonie en lituanie en pologne
en bulgarie en roumanie c'est à dire des
pays où il y aurait des bases donc ça
justifierait
une invasion de le craindre découvriront
dit invasion mais lorsque lorsque les
états unis ont bombardé l'irak ont parlé
d'intervention donc c'est un mot moi
j'aimerais savoir ce contexte était
différent oui je vais quand même savoir
ce que pense à la mécène au pouvoir et
oui qui n'avait d'ailleurs pas de la
médaille au mont houy qui n'avait
d'ailleurs pas d'armes de destruction
massive contrairement à ce qu'avaient
dit les amériques moi j'aimerais savoir
ce que dirait des états unis s'il y
avait un projet au mexique de
l'installation de bases militaires à 50
km au sud du rio grande des et face à la
californie l'arizona au texas a justifié
de détruire tout un pays pour vous quand
on voit ça s'est vu ce que j'observe
c'est que la crise de cuba en 1962 a été
très clair cuba est un pays libre
souverain et indépendant mais lens ou
crouch a fallu installer les missiles
une qualif j'ai dit soit vous retirer
soit c'est la guerre nucléaire c'est
vrai ou c'est pas vrai c'est vrai donc
là la même chose s'est passé n'ajoutons
aussi parce que depuis huit ans
les républiques autoproclamées de l'est
de l'ukraine sont victimes de
bombardements massifs du régime de kiev
alors je ne dis pas ça c'est vous qui le
dites en mai non non vous avez des
confrères qui l'ont dit dans les deux
sens oui mais en attendant en attendant
maintenant il faut faire quoi il faut
essayer encore une fois j'ai condamné
l'intervention de poutine qui est
contraire au droit international mais le
reste n'est pas contre on n'est pas
conforme en plus aux accords qu'elles
étaient dépassées entre le président
bush père et gorbatchev front
d'effondrement du temps ce socialisme
maintenant il faut faire quoi il faut
essayer d'amener tout le monde à la
raison on a affaire avec la russie quand
même à la première puissance nucléaire
mondiale avec 6250 ogives il a
d'ailleurs brandi à la manade sa nuque
donc on doit faire attention d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs la france fait attention
l'union européenne aussi parce que
lorsque monsieur macron dit qu'il réagit
l'envoie pas de troupes et madame parlé
à didier hd pas question en ukraine on
envoie des troupes en estonie en
roumanie c'est comme si vous aviez un
incendie dans un
énorme pas partie de l'otan oui mais si
vous voulez une idée l'otan l'isolant
mais ce que demande ce que demandait le
régime de kiev c'est justement d'avoir
un soutien militaire or bien entendu
aucun pays européen ni aucun pays de
l'otan les meilleurs 20 se sont mis
d'accord pas pour intervenir mais pour
livrer des armes pour le moment oui mais
je ne pense pas que ce soit une bonne
chose parce que ça veut dire qu'on va
jeter de l'huile sur le feu voilà on
risque d'ailleurs de disséminer des
armes dont on ne sait pas ce que
deviendront les missiles stinger ça peut
parler prendre des années pour essayer
de récupérer ensuite donc ça veut dire
quoi qu'il fallait c'est d'ukraine non
ce qui assaillent et parallèlement
sachant qu'on voit tous les jours le
peuple chrétien qui résistent qui
annoncent qu'ils vont peut-être
je suis d'accord qu'il faut arrêter
cette guerre mais mais ce qui me
chiffonne si vous voulez c'est que
regarder ce qui se passe avec les outils
au yémen regarder ce qui se passe au
congo dans l'est du congo il ya des
zones ans dans le monde il ya des
centaines de morts tous les jours et on
n'en parle pas donc il y à ici un art
hâtif spécifications 4 wii / france pas
un capitaine mais sur les grands médias
français on n'en parle pas les grands
médias nationaux
donc ce que je veux dire ici c'est que
si on est pour la paix on ne donne pas
des armes un des belligérants contre la
première puissance nucléaire mondiale on
essaie de faire aboutir la paix et donc
je pense qu'il faudrait avoir une
mission de bons offices mais qui ne peut
pas être rempli par messieurs macron
puisque nous faisons partie d'un des
deux camps ont fait partie de l'otan il
faut donc qu'il y ait une médiation je
vois que la chine s'est proposé comme
médiatrice c'est pas forcément la
meilleure des puissances il peut y avoir
un recours aussi à la cour
internationale de justice pour essayer
de mettre autour d'une table c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe les
négociations et je pense qu'il ya un
prendre un point fondamental en fait
c'est qu'il faut que l'occident
admettent que l'ukraine doit devenir un
pays neutre ne peut pas qui ne peut pas
qu'il est c'est ce que voudrait
revendications mais je ne sais pas ce
que veut l'ukraine le temps file donc on
va passer à autre jour notamment sur la
politique française et notamment sur vos
parrainages
vous n'y êtes pas encore vous avez
jusqu'au 4 mars à 10 demain 18h vous y
croyez trop joué j'ai fait un sauf que
le 4 mars ce sera la fin des réceptions
mais le nombre officiel sera connu le 8
mars par le conseil constitutionnel
écoutez on fait tout pour on a des
centaines de militants qui vont voir des
mecs le problème c'est que les maires
d'abord sont sous pression ils l'ont dit
pour le macbook beaucoup d'autres
candidats mentent et des défis on tue
les difficultés mais ce que j'observe
c'est que moi je n'ai aucun soutien
aucun secours de monsieur bayrou
qui semble-t-il à des parrainages qu'il
distribue et si je vois le comment ont
évolué les parrainage de monsieur
zemmour de monsieur mélenchon ou même de
monsieur poutou qui d'un seul coup on a
eu 90 de plus je me dis que ces
candidats là sont soutenus par un proche
du président de la république alors que
nous nous n'avons rien je me demande
nous donc si le fait de proposer la
sortie de l'union européenne de l'euro
et de l'otan et finalement c'est
peut-être quelque chose qu'on n'a plus
le droit de dire en france alors on a le
droit de le dire il quelques minutes sur
un plateau de télévision mais il faut
bien comprendre que si je ne suis pas
candidat et bien il n'y aura aucun
candidat en france à cette élection
décisive qui proposera aux français de
sortir de l'union européenne et de
l'otan auraient notamment de l'ontario
c'est notre analyse l'otan qui nous
entraîne dans un engrenage militaire et
l'europe ça nous en train de lire quoi
ce nombre d'entrés vous savez le rhdp
l'ue et l'otan c'est à peu près la même
chose j'ai l'article 42 du traité de
l'union européenne place la politique
étrangère de sécurité de défense de
l'union européenne sous la tutelle de
l'otan ce que je vois c'est que vous
avez entendu ce qui s'est passé vous
avez le président ukrainien qui
demandent l'adhésion rapide de l'ukraine
à l'union européenne j'ai vu que madame
salomé zourabichvili la président de la
géorgie demande à son tour l'adhésion
ghana on pourrait juger de sa c'est une
procédure qui prend normalement des
dizaines est-ce que les français se
rendent compte de louvain excuse si ce
sont vraiment des copains quand on voit
l'union européenne qui ce qui s'unit
comme comme elle est en train de nous
entraîne vers la guerre on a dit depuis
des décennies ou france se met au
emmanuel macron l'a rappelé hier ça on
n'est pas en guerre on n'est pas en
guerre contre la
fournit du matériel militaire lui crie
un délai non c'est pas aussi pour entrer
en guerre avec avec la russie moi je
croyais que la construction peine était
une oeuvre de paix si c'était une oeuvre
de paix on devrait proposer à la russie
d'entrer dans l'union européenne puisque
si paraît-il que c'est grâce à l'union
européenne qu'il n'y a pas de conflit
entre la france et d'allemagne danser en
fait l'union européenne est en train de
se transformer comme je le dis depuis 15
ans en inde phénomène agressif qui
risque de nous entraîner comme en 1914
par un jeu d'alliances d'automatique
vers un conflit planétaire il faut
mettre le holà à cette affaire ce sera
le mot de la fin merci monsieur
asselineau d'avoir été avec tôt et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci
beaucoup